I don't want to hurt your feelings but
that's not the you're not the first
person he's tried to get us to swing
with Kristen Bell swung by Conan O'Brien
late-night show on Tuesday where he
brought up what happened when her
husband Zack Shepherd appeared on the
show and he casually on the air
suggested a wife swap with you and my
wife switching it up this sounds like my
husband and I don't want to hurt your
feelings but that's not the you're not
the first person he's tried to get us to
swing with he's a very free spirit you
know I'm just yeah he's a very selfish
call I'm a horndog yeah also but around
my parents we say free spirit he just
loves people he loves the human frame
and he constantly suggests a different
dinner parties that we hang out yeah
really get to know each other
Kristen set the record straight though
saying we're not actually swinging with
anyone and last month the 36 year olds
ovt how she and Dax balance their busy
lives together only one of us works at a
time we have a lot of great people that
are our support system and we bring our
kids everywhere to work